welcome back to pocket X today is all
about the small stuff so it's going to
be a lot of rock work and grass and
things like that and those little pests
are going to actually create a lot of
lag which I didn't expect but during the
making of this episode I kind of dropped
down to six FPS to even for FPS at times
when zooming out which I think though
I'm not sure is due to the fact that you
don't get lower poly models of you zoom
out don't different levels of detail I'm
not completely sure about that but
basically the it's actually not running
all too well i'm actually already
running into black problems like roller
coaster q3 I mean I'm used to it at this
point but it was a bit of an issue
sometimes but it's it's not too big of a
problem really the wooden coaster i
think i'll rename to avalanche i don't i
don't actually remember whether I said
it in the last episode but I was going
to call that thing rolling thunder I
think I said that which was honestly
just the name that I had to quickly come
up with just to put it on the polytek
Nexus and I've got so many good
suggestions and I just think avalanche
is the best suggestion so far it packs
the Alpine theme it's a bit standard
honestly it's pretty common name but I
do like it and this little ride is
called forest explorer for the time
being I'm not sure if I want to keep
that name but then again names are not
too important i suppose it's just a bit
of a reference point and really all I'm
doing here at the moment is placing now
in a lot of grass which I've always kind
of missed in boloco second three and
it's it's kind of trying to find the
sort of balance between spamming a lot
of grass and having no 3d grants
whatsoever I actually saw a couple of
people on the polytek mixes threads who
actually use a lot of cross actually
create the idea that there is a lot of
talk Ross but I don't think I really
want to do that considering that these
things are enormous creators of lag at
the moment so I think I'll just keep it
down and just play some grass here and
there to make it look a little bit more
rugged and have a little bit more detail
in it but it's not really to 100% create
a realistic look of tall grass
everywhere that's something I don't
think I can really get in and that's
that really at which point I just kind
of do all sorts of random stuff in this
episode then I just kind of still had to
do to make the park like a little bit
better like I don't actually exactly
remember but small little tense and food
courts and a new ride which I [ __ ]
how I free I forgot to actually record
me making the foliage around the
swinging ship which I and at the end of
this video which is just exactly the
same reason has the reason that I didn't
have the foliage of the junior coaster
because I ran out of reps memory which
is actually turning out to become a
pretty big problem basically since I'm
being a lazy fat ass and I don't have to
commentary over all of these videos
because it's quite a big stash but I
currently still have like four episodes
more of parks eggs already on my pc and
I like constantly doing new stuff and I
have to find time in between to do the
commentary which is pretty much the only
ten minutes of my life usually each day
in which i just have a random stream of
consciousness and open and upload that
on YouTube that's pretty much that but
I'm being way too made her with that is
this thing is a bit of a pavilion I
figured from which you could look at the
roller wooden roller coaster I don't
know how much since it makes but I kind
of just wanted to fill the space and
have some sort of observation little
tents from which you can look at the
wooden roller coaster and surprisingly
early it almost has a bit of that Asian
sort of feeling I feel as if if I add
the western corners around the corners
of this roof it could even look at tiny
bit Asian but it's it's alpine or at
least it should be sort of alpine in the
meantime there haven't been any new
customs in reset so I can't really make
this park look more Alpine than it does
in the moment but one thing is which is
pretty good the fact that the most
recent updates which the developers gave
they actually added a Rico I mean they
added a pallet tool so you can actually
now save the colors that you're using is
not in the game yet that is uploaded so
it's really just the dev vlog but it's
really cool to see that it's
actually there and hopefully by the time
that this park is finished it's actually
usable in the uploaded game because it's
it is so amazing they did exactly what I
kind of wanted to do with the tour you
can not only save the college so you
don't have to save the hex codes into a
notepad file to save your college but
you can even save entire pallets so I
don't know if you can actually share
them though but you can just create
palettes for certain themes and open
those to get all the colors that you
need which is absolutely perfect and
pretty much what I wished for all this
time and that's gonna be a lot better
because right now actually need to spend
quite a bit of time each time digging up
my notepad file which I always lose
which has my colors in it and always
have to kind of leave the game for a
second to find the right color and
always pick the wrong color because I
don't give my colors names that make
sense like got some sort of almost white
yeah and that's exactly one of the
colors is called or boys white and
another one is called almost almost
whites which I figured we would seem fun
when I just added them but now every
time I try to find the exact shade of
white that I need it's kind of painful
but yeah I can't really use that just
yet and there's also the young the new
pre alpha has been released and I am
actually sort of debating whether i want
to make update videos which is some
random idea that pretty much is
completely ripped off from the Minecraft
community where you had these snapshots
anyone who's played Mycroft probably
knows that you had these snapshots which
would come out weekly I don't know if
they still do I haven't played the game
in way too long but I'm each week they
would have liked new little updates you
don't get it instantly into your game
but you can download the snapshot if you
wanted to and then you get all these
youtubers actually sharing videos of
what's new in the snapshot and what you
can do with it which I which I thought
was really cool and a lot more fun than
to just look at one big update thing
which just said remove this and at this
and removed herobrine which was pretty
much as one big wolf text which rarely
seem to make any sense whatsoever so I
might do that but I'm really not too
sure the updates of architectures are
really quite small and somewhat rare
compared to weekly snapshots at the
moment so it's just an idea that I might
want to play around with
but it's a bit of a good point perhaps
because the stuff that you're looking at
right now is released before the newest
updates is there so this was before this
stuff that has been added in the new
update which we actually already have in
the game which are castle walls new
pillars as well as some small bug fixes
and extra things that you can do with
parts for example and a really good
really good thing is the fact that they
actually added a bobsled coaster I
wouldn't be able to quite edit in this
park since well this was recorded before
that update came out but it's actually a
really cool thing and i love the bobsled
so far actually think it looks a lot
better than bellicose tycoon 3 but yeah
i might make videos on showing that
stuff that stuff off but I'm not really
too sure about it I mean that there's
still quite small updates and it's also
fun to well see for yourself what the
update is like that's actually what i
usually do i don't really check the
update things i just get into the game
and check all the windows and see what's
new it's actually quite fun to do that
and i might do that on the camera but
i'm not really sure and the last sort of
thing that I wanted to do to bring
actually back to the park here is I
wanted to have a lot of water in the
park I'm not sure if it's because it's
in the Netherlands I might just want to
say that this park is in the Netherlands
because it's completely flat sand that's
a good excuse for making a completely
flat park which honestly it's it's you
could call it extreme laziness which it
probably is but I'm not a big fan of
using terraforming in my pipes because
as good as it looks it is very painful
to work with but um I just kind of
wanted to have a little river flow
through the park and have some small
lakes connected to that which I think it
would be perfect with a little pirate
ship over it which is very disney-esque
and a bit of a ripoff really but it
looked too good not to do it especially
with all the foliage and awesome palm
trees and awesome phones from the
awesome Dino pack which you won't be
able to see because I forgot to remove
my reps files and now I didn't record it
so tough look I'm sorry about that I'm
but yeah in the end I think yeah you'll
see it next episode anyway in the end I
do think it looks
good and I like having all those phones
and palm trees and things like that I
don't know where the video just pours
over there but oh well and the amazing
thing is really that with all these
offset elements it's a bit annoying for
building since you can't raise all of
them but there are so many different
things that you can do with these
elements to make separate fences like
especially with all the new posts that
have come out you can raise them lower
than place them in different sections of
the grid to come to just make completely
different offenses which is really
awesome and something that I might want
to mess run with just a little bit more
than I currently do um but yeah that's
pretty much it I'm running out of time
again because I forgot to record the
foliage so I'll see you guys in the next
episode in which I'll magically have
that foliage and work on some other
stuff around this area